les consommateurs se comptent encore par
dizaines devant cette succursale de la
société québécoise du cannabis six mois
après sa légalisation pense qu'on a été
bien servis rapidement et tout ça mais
dans les semaines et les mois qui ont
suivi la légalisation
l'approvisionnement aura sans doute été
l'un des plus grands défis rapidement
après le 17 octobre les tablettes des
succursales québécoises ont été
complètement vidé les heures d'ouverture
considérablement réduite
tous les producteurs et tous les
détaillants à l'échelle du canada ont
vécu des défis cela dit la rapidité
d'exécution la rapidité de l'expansion
d'industrie non seulement est unique
mais c'est quand même assez
extraordinaire ce qui s'est passé dans
très peu de temps
la société québécoise du cannabis ne
dévoile pas ses chiffres pour le moment
mais affirme que de plus en plus de
variétés sont offertes en ligne comme en
magasin
un avis partagé par plusieurs
consommateurs de beaucoup de types de
plantes beaucoup de soupe d'huile
ça va vraiment mieux cotés choix c'est
même difficile de faire un choix
présentement je pense que les prix ont
monté un peu mais s'ils ont le choix ça
va c'est encore aujourd'hui c'est
difficile il n'y a pas assez de variétés
sur les tablettes
et deuxièmement il n'ya pas le stock il
n'a jamais assez les producteurs comme
exo cup l'un des principaux fournisseurs
de la escudé c'est ton conscient que le
travail est loin d'être terminé
ce qui est vraiment excitant c'est lé
prochain semant notamment parce que
l'arrivée sur le marché des produits
comestibles est prévue pour le 17
octobre 2019 pour faire compétition
marché légal il faut être en mesure
d'offrir aux consommateurs de cannabis
une variété de produits une variété de
consommer mais impossible de dire quand
les québécois auront accès à des
succursales ouvertes 7 jours par semaine
on compte 13 magasins dans la province
et trois autres doivent ouvrir leurs
portes d'ici l'été
mettez le bourg stock sur les tablettes
on a besoin ici qui me permettrait au
canada montréal